ladies and gentlemen of the reject
nation we are going to talk about a
subject that i'm sure
will be sensitive for many leave your
thoughts down below on what you think
about all this if you've already heard
and if you haven't heard we'll go
through it all and we'll give our
thoughts we are talking about
oscar fan favorite cheer movement
zack snyder did they deserve it i know
we're talking about ezra miller today
it's being reported uh by rolling stone
warner brothers held an emergency
meeting about the actor's future with
the company the meeting was to discuss
pausing all future projects involving
ezra miller and that toilet
got a lot of thoughts in the bathroom
over there as well as any public
appearance involving the actor himself
and this is coming hot off the heels of
of many alarming things needless to say
so you might have heard recently that he
was arrested and and you know in
fairness that's it wasn't a bad mug shot
you know no it was a great it was a
great shot people have to be lucky to
have that mug celebrity mug shots can be
a nasty business and i was like you know
what at least he got a not so bad if it
was a bad mug shot this situation
probably would have been way worse
honestly you know this the situation of
a mug shot can be so much more telling
of just how bad he was
in that moment he looks like the way we
react it looks like they got time to to
prepare for their bug shot
so where this stem from was according to
reports miller became agitated while at
a karaoke bar grabbed the microphone
from a woman singing and then reportedly
lunged after an another man who was
playing darts the couple filed a
restraining order against miller and
then the article goes on says miller
reportedly threatened to burn a couple
in hawaii last week according to court
documents surrounding their arrest i
don't know how to process them i am so
sorry stoion kojokariff
and his wife nigel hayes filed a
temporary restraining order against
miller after alleging that miller burst
into their bedroom and threatened to
burn them
and
of course i'm sure many of you already
remember the whole situation years ago
what feels like or was it a year ago i
don't know where ezra miller was caught
on camera choking a female fan i've had
some people say it was it was just a
stunt it was a goof i've heard other
people say that it wasn't he got
aggressive and that they probably paid
that woman to not do anything about it
the thing is i don't know and you
probably don't know because they never
said [ __ ] about it so we don't know
interested
we don't know what happened
right and i thought it was bizarre with
this whole thing with warner brothers of
the the firing and all the drama like
every time we talk about warner brothers
i feel like there's some weird dramas
slanted with them right there's like
stained with that a lot of people who've
been fired or been replaced a lot of
people felt it was unjust or unfair and
then other people who got to keep
working that they thought was unfair and
ezra miller they were like let's just
not say anything we can't afford another
one of these and now it seems like that
people are finally actually saying
something and i do think he should be
held accountable for his actions these
are very violent displays of behavior
and it sounds like a man who is quite
neurotic uh like i don't know this man
99.9 percent of you guys don't know this
man either sounds like he has some real
like mental health struggles that he has
to deal with and so he needs help and at
the same time if just because a person
has mental health struggles just because
they are suffering with something to
give the benefit of the doubt in that
regard i mean it seems pretty obvious
that doesn't give an excuse to the
behavior nor should he just be allowed
to get a pass on this it totally makes
sense to me because this behavior is on
going this is a continuous thing like
that choking fan incident i don't
remember how long ago that was but
enough time has passed to get to the
point where ezra miller could have you
know done enough work on himself to not
be
attacking people right yeah instead of
allowing it to get that much worse you
know like i i think about coming off of
the heels of will smith physically
assaulting chris rock he assaulted
individuals and the amount of
condemnation that people have thrown
will smith you know like well fair is
fair ezra miller should definitely
be really condemned for these actions
then too if we're pausing upcoming will
smith joints we should absolutely be
pausing upcoming ezra miller joints yeah
because the article's not saying they
discussed like replacing him or firing
him even though that's what this heavily
alludes to
i feel like he really got away with it
before
and he can't just get away with it again
that's basically where i'm standing with
this well maybe we're at the point now
too where love of the snyder verse will
no longer eclipse just like needing to
address bad behavior yeah like the whole
movement is about accountability part of
it is about accountability over
entertainment so now that's also being
reported that there was some insider on
the on the side of the flash who said
they didn't reveal who said this so
maybe it's just a rumor that he was
having like a lot of sort of mental
breakdowns while on set like apparently
ezra would get a thought in his head and
be like i don't know what i'm doing in
his defense i i feel like they haven't
known what they're doing with that flash
movie for the longest time
well i mean in isolation that would seem
like yeah a set that would be enough to
drive anybody into sort of a confusing
mixed up place or whatever or maybe yeah
equate to some weird onset behavior but
this does smack of a situation that has
only boiled over and gotten worse
because it's like with the removal of
time from the choking incident like if
nothing else had ever happened i would
be inclined to believe like oh yeah
maybe it was some kind of weird prank
between somebody he had it they had a
connection with that i i know nothing
about but now it does feel more like the
ladder of like maybe they paid that
person to keep quiet in hopes they could
contain this and it's just not working
out i mean i saw a tweet from ryan airy
this afternoon kind of identifying it as
addict behavior and i could absolutely
imagine that and that's something that
you know you can't really control on
your own after a certain amount of time
and when you're under this much pressure
and in the position of such notoriety
and such attention from everyone around
you know it's only a matter of time
before all that boils over the way he's
talked about his past experiences from
the little glimpses i've been able to
gather it sounds like he's had some type
of you know traumatic but anyone who
displays this kind of behavior obviously
would have some type of traumatic
unresolved things he has to deal with
and yeah talking about the whole thing
with addiction a lot of this is
theoretical and a lot of it is probable
regardless
that
he has to be held accountable for this
stuff and i don't know what the decision
is for it like you can't just replace
him in in the flash
movie at the same time like they need to
freaking finish this damn movie
and weirdly i'm like well if there is a
character you could replace i feel like
you could actually replace the flash
like i've heard fans already being like
they should have just made grand gusts
in him in the dc and i'm like well yeah
you're doing a multiverse movie so sure
just you know get a different actor to
play the flash they've already had like
14 batman's going on two of them alone
are in this one movie so i'm like sure
we'll get a different flash actor i
think it's so odd of how they've been so
tight-lipped it just seemed like he
wouldn't suffer any repercussions for
this type of behavior and i don't feel
like this is just another thing of like
will culture cancel culture like no this
is uh this is not okay people have to be
held to equal standards especially in
the parent company and warner brothers
so i don't feel like he should just get
a pass on all this and it's crazy it
sounds like they have like so many
things lined up with him and to begin
with the fantastic beasts movie that's
coming out and then you know of course
the flash movie as well and of course
with that there's probably future
projects in development to use ezra
miller as well well not to mention that
this flash has three versions of ezra
so it's like triple the johnny depp
problem all in one movie plus you've got
dumbledore to worry about you know i
mean i guess the question is is like the
forgiveness scale of celebrities ways
depending on whoever the individual is
that is casting judgment right for me i
cannot talk about like what i feel is
appropriate to do if he actually you
know is doing the actual work to better
himself if he if he is an alcoholic or
something if he is going to rehab if he
is getting some intensive therapy to
truly work through these issues you know
like he's a young guy he's only like 29
or something like that he's had a lot of
success and the way he talked about
things he's uh it sounds like he's had a
lot of traumatic experiences he grew up
in the entertainment industry which
for many child actors is really
troubling times so it's not far-fetched
to me that he would have an aggressive
behavior it's it's not far-fetched again
though not excusable the thing is is
that there has to be some type of
display of actual homework put in you
can't just say i'll change or release
some statement apologizing i feel like
the right thing to do is to be an
inspiration in the same way how we were
able to like see robert downey jr in a
new light
if someone would like oh wow their
problems were really front and center
but look at them now and i think ezra
miller kind of needs to do a similar
thing i don't feel like we can just
enable him yeah and it feels like
they're in a position where if ezra
miller does make the right choices and
does agree to maybe address some of this
behavior you know they could run their
flash movie take a break from that
character for a little while and then
either reinstate or correct down the
road with whatever that movie
establishes because i mean to me i'm
sitting here as thinking about wb they
seem to have a track record of being
finicky when it comes to how to progress
with their dc films especially films in
general sometimes especially on the big
franchise scale so i'm sitting here
wondering i know they've had to have
gone well do we need to recast again how
do we not have to scrap this entire
movie and it seems like a lot of that
could also come down to whatever ezra
miller and you know his camp decides to
do their camp decides to do so it does
present a sort of fascinating and very
woeful juncture for wb to me because
it's like they're just trying to get
their dc universe back on track and it
seems like it's gotten to a point where
they maybe wanted to keep this as silent
as possible and just can't anymore and
so i don't envy the position that
they're in because it seems like it's a
mess for everyone
patron of the day shout out
yeah guys what do you think is the
proper course of action here so should
he be i feel like he has to disappear
from the spotlight for a while you can't
keep a guy like that in the spotlight
you know and expect him to really grow
and change going around the world doing
pressing yeah things nah oh a thousand
percent but all right guys
i love ending these videos thanks for
being here bye
[Music]